okay well thanks for sitting down with
us you got a big crowd today at the
frontier Center luncheon uh you've said
that you're a prairie guy at heart nice
to be back here you see big uh big gains
to be made on the Prairies absolutely
it's the Prairie Common Sense values
that raised me uh you know as I said in
my speech
I was born of a 16 year old mother who
couldn't raise me so she put me up for
adoption to two School teachers and they
always taught me that it didn't matter
where I came from but where I was going
and that's the country I want for my
kids but it's not the country people
feel with right now people feel trapped
doesn't matter how hard they work their
paychecks get chewed up by Trudeau's
high taxes or the inflation that he's
caused the fact they can't afford a home
after seven years of Trudeau in power
so I want to give turn that hurt into
hope and I believe that message of Hope
will resonate across the Prairies where
I come from you know you talked about
the cost of living people are just being
crushed by this doesn't seem to matter
where you are in this country people are
feeling it what would you I mean if
you're the Prime Minister what would you
could you have avoided this or what
would you be doing uh if you couldn't
avoid it and you're in this position
right now how do you get out of it what
do you what do you do to offer relief
other than
you know government throwing government
money at people which you've said that
you wouldn't you don't think it's that's
the answer right well the Trudeau
government's causing the inflation the
half trillion dollars of inflationary
deficits have bid up the goods we buy
and the interest we pay throwing money
away on Serb payments for prisoners and
for uh dead people and giving uh seven
billion more in in contracts to
high-priced Consultants all that waste
is making life more expensive so I get
cut the waste
cap to spending and get rid of the
liberal NDP carbon tax and that's the
big disagreement now of course the
Liberals and NDP want a triple triple
triple the carbon tax on your heat your
gas your groceries that's going to crush
families I won't allow it I'm going to
get rid of the carbon tax and fight
climate change with technology not taxes
what sort of Technology what are you
thinking would be the answer to I mean
obviously we have a climate crisis I
think everybody kind of agrees with that
now what's the technological escape from
that if it's not uh the carbon tax well
instead of making traditional energy
more expensive we have to make carbon
free Alternatives more affordable so
quickly approve more hydroelectric dams
to produce emissions free electricity to
approved nuclear power so that we can
replace Coal Fire plants allow the oil
and gas sector to invest in carbon
capture to capture the carbon in the
ground rather than putting it into the
air and to produce the metals of
electrification here in Canada produce
them the lithium the Cobalt the graphite
for electric car batteries in Canada
powered by Hydro so that we have
electric cars that are made in an
environmentally friendly way that's how
we're going to make it possible for
people to make the switch without
driving our working class into miserable
poverty which is what the NDP liberal
costly Coalition is doing now
you mentioned the hydro I mean lots of
First Nations communities have been
devastated by Hydro development in their
areas so there's that but then also you
know nuclear power
are you worried at all there's not
nobody even has anything to do with the
nuclear waste yet so should we be
producing more power when we haven't
figured out what to do with the waste is
that smart
well Ontario gets half of its energy
from nuclear right now and we have safe
disposal of it there is then this is
something we have to be very clear about
there is no carbon free future without
nuclear power that's just a physical and
mathematical fact and because there's no
other source that can meet the needs of
our civilization so we have to use Clean
safe nuclear power the way Ontario has
been doing the way France has been doing
for decades now and we can do it we have
to do it and that's the way we're going
to reduce the emissions from our
electrical sector but where do you put
the waste though it's stored right now
there's not really my understanding is
that there's not really an end uh in
sight for like what you do with that
stored weight you can't really store it
forever right you store you can you can
store waste and you also there are new
technological
um um advancements that leave less waste
behind we need to there's recent
breakthroughs in nuclear fusion there's
small modular reactors these
breakthroughs will be absolutely
necessary because the only way to power
our future is through hydroelectricity
and nuclear power the other sources
solar and wind they're fine but they
don't have they can't have the capacity
and they're variable they only they only
Power us when the wind blows and The Sun
Shines we need base load power and that
has to come from hydro and nuclear
um I want to switch gears to air travel
I know you I think everybody I
understand you guys even had your own
little bit of hassles with traveling the
other day
um you've said you know government
should be less intrusive in our lives
less regulation
um I feel like but you said that this
government should have done more with
the air travel nightmares that we've had
what I guess would you have done uh in
similar circumstance if you were the uh
the prime minister
well first of all I want to promote more
competition in our Airline sector we
have very little competition and that's
why the airlines think they can get away
with mistreating US airlines are federal
responsibility they're federally
regulated airports are federally
mandated and under Justin Trudeau are
Airlines and our airports have been a
disaster an absolute disaster and we had
winter before Justin Trudeau we didn't
have Airline catastrophe like we have
now his total incompetence in managing
Federal responsibilities whether it's
airports Airlines passports immigration
backlogs his total incompetence is
harming the lives of everyday people as
we've seen with the catastrophic Air
Service we had there are thirty thousand
Federal complaints by Canadians against
the airlines to Justin Trudeau's
Transportation agency that are in a
backlog
they have to wait 18 months for
Trudeau's government to rule on those
complaints no wonder the airlines aren't
worried and meanwhile the Trudeau
government gets no fines out of those
companies for having broken their
commitments to their customers and
countries around the world have much
better faster and more affordable
Airline service than we do in Trudeau's
Canada what would you want to see them
do right now to kind of write that wrong
or to fix it too so at least it doesn't
happen again I mean well for obviously
he's got a Trudeau's got to clear his
backlog of 30 000 complaints how do you
do that well get your bureaucracy
working he has more bureaucrats working
more bureaucrats getting paid right now
thirty thousand more and yet we can't
get passports can't process Airline
complaints can't process immigration so
it's his personal incompetence that
means that we're paying more for Less we
need a competent prime minister with a
bureaucracy that actually gets things
done to serve the people would you cut
the bureaucracy or you think they just
should be working smarter I think we can
get more productivity uh out of our
government right now you know he's
spending 70 percent more
on high-priced Consultants that adds up
to seven billion dollars the total
budget for high-priced Consultants today
17 billion dollars that works out to
more than one thousand dollars for every
family in Canada think about that per
second your family is spending a
thousand dollars in federal taxes for
Justin Trudeau's high price Consultants
that's an abject waste of money and so
is his government
um let's move on to reconciliation then
so uh I know that had been a big
campaign promise of this government you
know we want to move forward on
reconciliation you've got the Truth and
Reconciliation calls to action
um there's that's not moving super
quickly we've got undrip not moving
super quickly would there be a change a
shift in direction under uh a parap
government in terms of where Canada goes
down the reconciliation path
yes I mean with Trudeau it's been a lot
of symbolism
and speeches and drama but no results so
I would take a different approach one we
need to get clean drinking water on
every reserve and every community and I
would uh contract the infrastructure
companies and I would say to them they
don't get paid until the water the clean
water is available and some of their pay
will be contingent on those Clean Water
Systems continuing to work for years to
come so they can't build a faulty system
get paid and buzz off they have to get
the job done to serve because our first
Nations people deserve clean drinking
water Point number two the Indian Act is
a disaster it is a racist Colonial
hangover that gives all the control to
self-serving and incompetent politicians
bureaucrats and lobbyists in Ottawa
takes away the control from the First
Nations themselves I want to make it
easier for First Nations that want to
opt out of the Indian Act to do so so
that they can control their own money
their own land their own resources and
their own decisions I believe First
Nations know what's good for them and
the problem in this country has been a
top-down colonial government in Ottawa
that has imposed its will against the
will of the First Nations people and
finally
I'm going to make it possible for those
First Nations who choose to develop
their resources and Commerce in their
communities to keep the money rather
than having it go to Ottawa and then
then the people have to go and ask the
bureaucrats for their own money back I
want to create a new model that will
allow First Nations to keep their money
and benefit their people so that they
can fulfill their purpose and their
Destiny and that's that's my vision
there's been uh and I'm not sure if
there's something you would know about
but
um there has been some people who have
talked about status Indians being able
to sign off on their status just be you
know be essentially landlords of the
land here I get my my status card back
and you as living on this land would pay
me sort of almost a rent I'm not sure if
this is a concept that you've been
familiar with the Sheila North had
worked on it a little bit I just went
kind of hatched here in Winnipeg but
that idea of uh you know it's just kind
of another step away from that Indian
Act mentality of how Canada and
Indigenous people have been forced to
for First Nations people have been
forced to to live here is that something
you would think about
well I know there have been a lot of
very successful First Nations who do
have lease arrangements so you know for
example they've been taked in band has
developed Wineries and real estate and
other Commerce with the goal of getting
10 million dollars of Revenue per year
for their local services
and the soyuz ban the First Nations uh
in all across British Columbia actually
those are in Prime real estate it's a
little different if you're living in
Garden Hill right yeah maximizing your
your resources in some of these
communities certainly but I was more
talking specifically about individuals
can say you know you pay me 25 000 a
year
and just throwing that number out there
I don't have um a status card I'm not
tax exempts now like you're selling
you're trading in that status card
um and I had heard that you know that's
something that perhaps uh conservatives
would would be hoping to advance I'm not
familiar with that particular proposal
but um yeah so I can't comment on it
okay uh what about and this speaks to
the we just had headlines yesterday
about the graves more Graves potentially
these would be across the former
residential school sites in Canada we
know this this was laid out in the 2015
TRC commission
um this is going to be a years-long
program process of First Nations people
communities looking for these Graves is
that something you know I know this
government has said we support it
whatever it is you know we fund it is
that the tech that you would take as
well we would fully fund all the
inquiries into the human remains at the
or near the sites of residential schools
uh and my last question I guess would be
for you uh Winnipeg looking at Manitoba
for the next election
um I think you guys are going to regain
a big stronghold on that of this area
look uh people are suffering in Winnipeg
under Justin Trudeau they can't afford
the young people can't afford Homes
single moms are putting water in their
milk because they can't afford groceries
for their kids we have homelessness and
Drug overdoses and violent crime is up
32 percent under Justin Trudeau's
policies people want to change in
Winnipeg that will give them back
control of their paycheck through lower
taxes and less inflation that will put
violent repeat habitual offenders Behind
Bars while respecting law-abiding
hunters and Anglers and that's the
change that I'm going to bring I'm going
to put give winnipeggers control of
their own lives their paychecks and
their Futures and that's why I believe I
will win and Winnipeg and across
Manitoba I know I said that was my last
question but I have one more because you
brought up crime and that's a very good
one especially here in Winnipeg
what is the solution to Rising crime I
mean we've got drug problems we've got
mental health that's not being addressed
I know you had mentioned you know the
the BC model didn't appeal to you as
much as the Alberta model is there a
Manitoba model or is there a
one-size-fits all
well recovery and treatment for a
drug-free life that's the future right
now people can't get recovery there
aren't beds available and while Justin
Trudeau wastes billions of dollars
buying back hunting rifles and taking
away the hunting rights of First Nations
people supposedly
he thinks this is going to help fight
crime I put those resources into
reinforcing our borders against drugs
and gun Smugglers
and on recovery and treatment for drug
addicts we know it's possible I met a
lady just in Tim's just yesterday a
waitress who had been a nurse got
addicted to opioids because of course
the lying dirt bag pharmaceutical
companies told her that it was safe she
got addicted she lost her kids but guess
what she got into a recovery program and
she turned her life around and now she's
working she has an income she's
responsible member of our community it
proves that no matter how far lost
people feel like they are there is hope
to turn it around we need to get them
the recovery and treatment to make that
possible you'd give the provinces that
money for that like I guess and increase
health care spending would you do it
with no strings like they're asking
because then they could use it for
exactly these types of programs that
you're talking about I'll have a very
clear recovery and treatment proposal
coming and it will get results we're not
just going to throw money around I want
beds I want counselors detox medication
that will help withdrawal and overdoses
they're all going to be part of my plan
and we will get we will rescue the lives
of our friends our neighbors our
brothers and sisters who who have fallen
victim to this horrific addiction crisis
we will get them back we'll save their
lives and we'll put them back in control
of their lives
well we thank you for taking time sit
down with us today thank you pleasure
covered lots of ground there yes great
to be with you and uh wonderful to be
back on the prairies